leave oils here with GameSpot I'm
standing with Drew here at the order
1886 now there have been so many zombie
games that when we first saw this we're
like yes a werewolf game is that what
we're seeing are these these werewolves
what are these creatures yes they are
what we actually showed on Monday at the
press conference was the reveal of the
half-breeds the werewolves the lichens
basically in our game what are they how
did they come to be the premise of the
the IP itself is that a long time ago
hundreds of years ago the humanity
changes evolves in a different direction
a part of humanity splits and
genetically become different and the
developed traits that are not
necessarily wolf traits or other traits
but they're equated visually to to being
werewolves so the first time people see
these this these evolved humans people
equate it to what they've heard about
werewolves in their midst and legends
and they go wow that should be that
there must be a werewolf and that's how
the name comes to be it's not really
because there are man wolf you know
mixes about the setting and the time
periods so the game is set in in
Victorian era London post-industrial
revolution London the thing about it is
that it was it was a great place to
actually you know use as kind of a
foundation to set the story that world
at London of that that time 1886 is
literally the center of the world we
used a lot of real-world events real
world people in there you'll see you'll
be able to see that in the game and the
reason why we did that is it because we
wanted people to have attachment to what
they would see you not just play a game
but play a game in a world that we know
already it could have actually happened
let's talk a little bit about the
characters are you stuck playing one
character can you choose the game is
really seen through the eyes of Galahad
Sir Galahad and and the story actually
is is really seen through his actions
and the events that happen in the game
so yes it is a single-player game and
it's a third-person action shooter but
what's interesting about it is that the
cast in the game will come in and out
very very often we didn't build a game
with like just two or three main
characters what you'll see in the game
that there is a plethora of characters
that I
coming in out of the story I'm not sure
you know how in death didn't go but this
Sir Galahad like what what's his deal
like why is he the guy who has to go get
rid of these things
well he's part of an order and that's
the name of the game the order 1886 this
order has existed for a long long time
for centuries as a matter of fact he was
built out of the knights of the round
table
when Arthur basically brought the best
of the best together to fight what they
felt was the evil in the world which was
the half-breeds so we twisted the author
and legend a little bit for our own
purposes and Galahad is is one of these
Knights but the interesting thing about
these guys is that they are not they are
human but they're not really because
they've lived longer than regular human
beings they have this this this elixir
called the black water that gives them
longevity and they've lived for multiple
lifetimes seeing their loved ones die
and all that so these these are battle
worn you know cursed soldiers we you've
seen some stuff so the other cast
members that he's going to be working
with can you talk a little bit about you
know how he does work with them and
their powers their moves their classes
how that over so the main squad is
composed of four people Galahad of
course is the main one the squad leader
is is sir Percival Sebastian Mallory
there's another Knight called Lady grain
her real name is ISA Bodega and we have
a another character fourth character
called well who's the mark yo Lafayette
the Marquis de Lafayette is the actual
real Marquis de Lafayette from our world
that we've again were used for own
purposes the interesting thing about
their dynamic is that each of them
brings a different layer with it's a
little light hardness some one of them
actually is a very much closer to the
main character so as as as player
characters as as game characters they do
the same thing they're all Knights right
and they use different weapons but
really they're there to further the
story and actually to reveal this whole
this IP to the other player very stoked
for this game thank you so much alright
Twitterverse tell me what you think
tweet me at least Boyles use the hashtag
GameSpot III tell me what you think
about the order 1886 here at e3
you